there's a sign
at the entrance to your gym that reads
for every moment of triumph
it's a quote by hunter s thompson it
reads for every moment of triumph
for every instance of beauty many souls
must be trampled
what does this quote me do that quote to
me is about
mostly about sacrifice
and it's about to achieve anything great
or anything beautiful or to triumph
you have to have sacrificed so many
things to get there
unless you're the most unbelievably
genetically gifted
person in the world and greatness is
just
you know falls upon you it's just
raining from the sky i think
on your path to greatness on your path
to success and triumph
you leave a lot of carnage in your wake
personal relationships
other goals things that you didn't
pursue um
you know other unfulfilled dreams and
you kind of have to sell a lot of that
out
in order to be really the the
at the the peak of your field or or what
you want to be
um i know that that's happened in my
life i mean there's
tons and tons of relationships that you
know
couldn't survive the way that i was
living my life because when i was trying
to be a big time fighter
or like when i was just training all the
time tons of relationships
uh dissolved themselves naturally some
not so naturally
some people get it some people don't get
it some people hate you
you miss tons of other opportunities and
i think that's kind of what that quote
means to me
it's about sacrifice it's about you're
giving up what you want now for what you
want more
and it's the the trampling of souls
it's messy too because it's not clear
what
what the right path is like that
sacrifice
is not obvious that um that's those are
the right sacrifices to make you might
be
you might be ruining your own life but
the the fact that you're willing to take
that risk
and uh sort of go
all in on the whether it's stupid or not
to go all in on something
that the possib the possibility of
creating something beautiful is there
who says it's stupid if you're going all
in on it you don't think it's stupid
someone else might think it's stupid but
i mean who really cares
you